performing a literature review is an
important step in conducting research as
it allows you to gain the comprehensive
understanding of the existing literature
on The Talk page so hi I'm Julius Fraser
third year PhD student in computational
neuroscience and today I want to talk
about my literature review workflow so I
have had to read a lot of papers over
the last few years and to keep a
comprehensive book or a comprehensive
system that allows you to synthesize all
these papers is actually quite difficult
and I think I've finally kind of got
there so I want to introduce you to my
system such that you may also benefit
from it and hopefully read a lot more
papers for your PhD or if you're a
student for your research work so let's
get straight into it so there are six
steps that I want to introduce you to
and the first one is to Define your
research question clearly I think if you
dive into research without having clear
research question it's actually really
overwhelming the amount of research that
you will find in the amount of papers
that you will find so usually it's quite
good to already know beforehand what
kind of research question you would like
to dive into so for example today we're
going to take the example of the
Bayesian brain so if you want to learn
more about the patient brain your
research question could be for example
the distribution brain what does it mean
how does it work etc so the second step
is to find a good review and find the
accompanying relevant research on scopus
so I personally like scopus the most as
I think it's the most comprehensive
knowledge bank right now on the internet
but there are a few other knowledge
banks that I will list down below and on
these type of websites you can find
relevant books articles and reviews but
the thing I like most about scopus is
that you can also list the articles
based on highest Citation for example
the authors that wrote it when it was
written and I find it pretty intuitive
how the paper system is structured
whereas for example on Google Scholar
even though I sometimes do use it it is
sometimes a little bit a black box how
they organize nice the papers so in
scope is usually the first thing I do if
I'm new to a topic I find a review so
you can just Google like what I'm doing
right now so Bayesian brain review and
then you search and usually I list it by
the highest citations if I don't know
that much about the field yet but this
does mean that newer articles go more to
the bottom but and then for example this
one adaptation will bring the role of
uncertainty and neural coding and
computing so I would probably select
this one and then try to find the paper
and another thing that I do like to do
is that I do like to see in the field
which authors have published the most so
this you can do on scope as you can see
which authors has published the most so
for example for the Beijing brain core
firsten has published a lot um which I
also already knew but if you're new to
computational Neuroscience lookup
conference and he has done some amazing
work and I think by also looking at the
authors then you also know which people
you should follow which are the most
contributing authors in this field so
then the next thing that I do after I
have found the articles that I like and
that I want to read a little bit more
then I usually import them in zotero and
start highlighting and reading in zotero
so the thing you want to do with
highlighting and reading is that you
want to look for patterns you want to
think of questions you want to see what
kind of open gaps or gaps in the
literature there are and I have made a
video about how I usually go through
through certain scientific articles that
you can find right here so for example
if I have this paper that I want to read
so for example in this case predictive
coding an account of the mirror neural
system then I click on the add-on from
zotero and you can select here the map
that you want to save it to so usually I
have for every paper that I'm writing
for every topic that I'm researching and
usually also nowadays for YouTube videos
I have a separate map on my zotero that
I link all the Articles to so I save it
automatically in this way to this map
and what you can then see in zotero is
that all your papers are listed here it
usually also automatically downloads PDF
which I really like if it's available if
it's not available you sometimes have to
add it and then the thing that I do is I
go over the paper and highlight all the
parts that I find interesting and that I
want to reference so this for me is
really where I do my rough reading where
I do my first reading and also where I
collect all my papers so I highly
encourage you to make different folders
for different projects that you have
because I think the end of your PhD you
will have probably read over 200 papers
and if you just all have them at the
same place like what I did at the
beginning it becomes really unstructured
super fast so then the fourth step that
I do is I open research rapid and I
import my zotero into research wrapping
so the thing that I like about research
Fabrics you can see it here so for
example these are papers that I read in
2022 this is a map I make and for
example here's the history and future of
the Bayesian brain and then you can look
for similar works so you have here all
the similar works and the thing I like
about it is that you have this kind of
graph like structure so you can really
see what important notes are so for
example Kristen Carl frister were a
really important paper Lily crab and
also these others and I think by looking
at it this way I usually uncover the key
papers in certain research areas or
certain topics which sometimes is a bit
hard to see if you are just listing the
papers in zotero so for me this is
really a good way to get a visual
overview of all the material that has
been written in the field so the next
thing I do is I organize it in notion so
all the highlights that I've made all
the things that I've thought about it
usually can be synthesized down into one
question for example one statement one
main fact that I want to remember and
usually I put this in the project that
I'm thinking about so I've made a video
already about how I use notion as my
second brain and I really think having
all the main or key points of every
article in one place for me at least has
really been beneficial and I do know
sometimes this is a little bit a hassle
to transfer this so I have thought about
like an automatic transfer but I'm not
still super satisfied about it so if you
have a way that you automatically link
your zotero to your notion let me know
in the comments down below and the last
step step six is to really synthesize
the literature into your own review and
this is not something that I always do
but sometimes your professor asks you
for example to write a review paper or
you have to write a certain part of a
review for an article or a course you're
following and I think actually this part
is the most interesting because
acquiring all the knowledge although it
takes some skill it's not really an
inherent ability but actually thinking
about the knowledge really interpreting
it seeing where the gaps lie thinking of
your own questions is where it becomes
really interesting so if you want to
know how I do it let me know down in the
comments but I do think in general just
thinking about it for a moment and
sitting down and writing your thoughts
down after you've read all the
literature already will take you quite
far so of course doing a full literature
review is a really time consuming
process and I also realized that but I
do think it's a key part of your PhD
that I also sometimes forget about
because when you're doing research and
when you're thinking about thoughts and
everything you sometimes forget that
there's already so much knowledge that
has been written about a certain topic
so I hope that my tips helped you a
little bit and that my workflow will
speed up your process us of doing this
quite tedious work sometimes and let me
know if you have any tips for me I would
love to hear so put it down in the
comments below and otherwise see you
next week bye